[Music]
let's do a hard left here for a second
and talk about
[ __ ] so you have a chapter
on [ __ ]
and i think the opening line under the
summary is plenty of people think i'm an
[ __ ] so
could you
and maybe a way to approach this is just
to ask you
what the
what the what the right breed of [ __ ]
is and not not all [ __ ] are created
equal so we don't have to go through all
of the the variations the different
species that you spec out we could
but
why why have plenty of people thought
that you're an [ __ ] and and how would
you kind of delineate
acceptable versus unacceptable [ __ ]
okay so this was a chapter that was very
hard to write
it took seven or eight full rewrites to
get there
and
it was very cathartic the reason being
is that
in my heart of hearts
i know
that
who i am and i and i've had
significant people tell me i
i really try not to be an [ __ ] okay
but there are certain things that are
core to me whether that's ethics morals
values or certain product features that
need to happen and they have to happen
with a certain quality level certain
customer experience or certain
technologies that need to exist and you
push and you push and you push
because you're trying to deliver for the
customer
so there are these [ __ ] and you know
even people have called steve that too
right people have all said oh yeah
the question is is motivation
what is motivating that no when i mean
behavior i mean like pushing people i'm
not saying offending people i'm not
saying degrading people i'm not saying
you're worthless that should never be
allowed period no bullying that none of
that should be allowed but challenging
people pushing them to be better pushing
themselves to be better the team to be
better making the product better that
does not make an [ __ ] that makes
somebody who cares and i care so much
that it may come off as an [ __ ] but
it's just that passion and that caring
that matters because it's all in service
of the customer and the team slash
company slash mission
a lot of times when you see [ __ ]
it's about them their ego and their
self-centeredness
so really you have to understand why
[ __ ]
who might feel that way you know the
knee-jerk reaction oh he's an [ __ ]
he's just always on my back
well are they literally degrading you
are they making you feel less are they
pushing you down so they feel better
that is definitely an [ __ ] if they're
there to push the details to really make
sure everybody's
doing their best without
insulting them without like telling them
whatever
just horrible behavior but making people
go white and asking why five times why
is why can't we do this why can't we do
this why can't we do this to me
that is as we say a passionate hurricane
in the book somebody who people don't
always like to work with but
at the time but usually years weeks
months years later they go my god that
was an amazing experience and yes it
sucked and yes it was hard but i did the
best work i possibly could and it was in
in service of our mission
that's what matters and so you have to
really delineate the two even though
there are characteristics that might be
shared or ways that you react the person
who's on the other side react to it be
like oh you know they're defensive or
they're worried about their ego or
they're getting bruised
if it's about the work and it's about
the mission not about the person then
that's really the delineation there
for those people wondering where i
pulled out
the the opening salvo
in the office with hr at the beginning
of our conversation that was from that
chapter so you also give practical
advice on how to deal with sort of
political [ __ ] with machiavellian
techniques sometimes they don't always
work but sometimes you have to try you
have to try because sometimes people are
just having a bad day or sometimes
they're just scared and you just got to
build a relationship with them but yeah
sometimes it isn't the case and
sometimes you just have to get away if
no one can help you
yeah sometimes the answer is quitting
exactly
you